I have good and bad news simultaneously
for you about the nomination to the
Supreme Court of Neil Gorsuch the Senate
Judiciary Committee has voted to advance
the Supreme Court nomination of Neil
Gorsuch to the full Senate that's bad he
got out of committee the slightly good
news is that as of yesterday Senate
Democrats have enough opposing votes to
carry out a successful filibuster to
block the nomination normally you need
for a Supreme Court pick 60 votes in
favor in the full Senate boat and
because there are democratic senators
mark warner dianne feinstein patrick
leahy and chris coons who said they will
vote against Gorsuch that means that
they will be short of the 60 votes that
they need this would be the first ever
successful filibuster of Supreme Court
nominee at the full Senate level but
more bad news this doesn't mean Gorsuch
won't be confirmed because what
Republicans can do is vote to change the
rules of the Senate to make it so that
Neil Gorsuch only needs 51 votes to be
confirmed if you've heard about the
nuclear option bandied about this is
what we're talking about and it's so
disturbing Pat that the rules are you
need 60 votes but you only need 51 votes
to change the rules to no longer need 60
votes and only need 51 votes and it's
still a symbolic victory after what
Republicans did to Merrick garland
President Barack Obama's nominee and
saying we're not even going to listen to
confirmation hearings because Obama's in
his last year of his presidency I fully
support Democrats doing anything they
can to block this confirmation it seems
that what they can do is force
Republicans to use the nuclear option
the Democrats had to do something
because otherwise they would be seen as
the pushover party yeah you know this is
just teaching us that elections have
consequences because Neil gorvich is 49
years old he's going to be on the court
for a generation at least and the big
concern is if you know Ruth Bader
Ginsburg or Anthony Kennedy or Stephen
Breyer yeah either either pass away or
retire what's going to be the next
course of action well the one way in
which change
the rules could backfire for Republicans
would be if the justices you mentioned
vacate their seats after 2018 if Trump's
presidency continues to implode it could
lead to Democrats taking over the Senate
in 2018 meaning that if the rules get
changed to where you only need 51 votes
to approve to confirm a Supreme Court
justice you could see a this completely
backfire on Republicans under Trump in
2018 and 2019 bet again i'm looking for
a silver lining here I think that's when
the real site will come because Neal
course which is considered baby Scalia
and was back to be replacing Scalia's
seat so it won't really change the
identity of the court at least for now
the balance that next that next
appointment is what I think really
matters it's not a guarantee that the
nuclear option will happen right if
three or more Republicans defect from
the nuclear option the democratic
filibuster would hold if none or one or
two Republicans vote against the nuclear
option then you you're going to have a
different situation here and Gorsuch
will ultimately be confirmed uh I don't
know I mean it's it's good news it's bad
news and of course even if this doesn't
stop Gorsuch I believe that this is
absolutely the right move but there's a
bigger reason why why we should be
blocking Gorsuch should we be confirming
a Supreme Court justice nominated by a
president whose legitimacy as president
is being investigated by the House
Senate and FBI that alone is a reason to
say shut it down until we have an answer
you know I've taken my position on this
I think Democrats should definitely
obstruct as much as they can and vote
against him yeah but I'm not willing to
tithe Gorsuch too much to the Russia
controversy you're going to appoint
someone for life on the word of a
president who may have been elected by
colluding with a non friendly foreign
power I passing you know so what if
Trump is an illegitimate president than
is going to irrevocably change the
future of the American judiciary for 20
to 30 years let's just vote him in Iowa
genet president doesn't really mean
anything it doesn't know how does it not
mean anything just looking at the
Constitution there
no process that would undermine Donald
Trump's ability to do anything even
while he's under investigation while
that may be true and I don't know if it
is this is a reason why Democrats should
pull out every stop to prevent this
confirmation from happening